[Música]
e tudo é diferente
todos os bairros
para mim a princesa da população é
linda como uma pera
você não deve passar
[Música]
não deve ser e enquanto
e quando você acredita
olha como você vai correr
se você é a flor uma semente
e eu rio quando eles esbarram em você
uma estrela é a que vai brilhar mais
[Música]
como esta vida
e parar de cantar por um amor
[Música]
sim
Eu te dou essa merda também
[Música]
isso é o que eles não querem
florescer
Pimenta
[Música]
usado e mais fino
quando você crescer você vai ver como ele progride totalmente
a flor mais bonita quando eu olho para você rainha
quando você os ama
Eu sou uma estrela será a que mais vai
brilhar
[Música]
para
Thomas Padilha
Deus
[Música]
aquele que vai mais